[Applause]  one of the best passing big man in the  league has ever seen  he's a three-time all-star this game is  no joke  but they called him the joker from the  [Applause]  [Music]  demon  a two-time nba mvp his crisscross is so  so deaf considered one of the greatest  scorers ever  ever ever ever this is his seventh  all-star appearance  from the golden state warriors stephen  [Applause]  nba defensive player of the year and  back-to-back mvp  in his one two three full  field all-star game for the milwaukee  vote  [Applause]  giannis  but he's also the captain and four-time  finals mvp  four-time mcdonald's mvp you want to be  down with the king  representing the los angeles lakers  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  this is team lebron  and these are your 2021 nba  all-stars